hi i'm maria today a friend will be
challenging me to take a popular food
and
make it fancy today's friend is
arya
let's see what aria wants me to make
fancy today hi really it's been too long
the thing i would like you to try and
make fancy for me are dino nuggets
they're comfort food they're comfort
treat i love dipping them in barbecue
sauce and ketchup
i'm very excited for this challenge
rourie i have high expectations i've
tasted many of your fancy creations in
the past and i've loved all of them and
i've scared you several times in
proclaiming how much i love them and i'm
still very excited to try whatever
masterpiece you come up with dino
nuggets nuggets shaped like a dinosaur
i've never had this before not dinosaur
shape not a culinary school
i'm also not familiar with old dinosaurs
t-rex is the one with like tiny hands
right
which one's the triceratops
why do you know so much they look very
friendly oh that's herb
oh they have a name what about this guy
he's from tulsa
so they have like whole story behind it
yeah petra and she likes to read and she
does karate and plays the violin
i think they started developing
character from petra and they got bored
let's see the ingredients everything is
something i can pronounce
so this is the t-rex
it's not very good
i like the texture i like the crunchy
outside it's not bad with ketchup
but nugget by itself has almost no
flavor that's the area i have to improve
like my personal taste it doesn't need
to be dinosaur shape seems like dinosaur
is very important for arya
i'm trying to recreate jurassic ala on
the plate it's kind of fun
i take it back i want my all food
dinosaur shape from now nuggets are
complete food so i think it's difficult
to change this to something else but i
have an idea and i'm excited to make it
fancy
right here's what i got carrots parsley
broccoli celery eggs radish butter
frozen thyme frozen peas red pepper
onion and garlic from the pantry i got
black pepper salt flour sugar bay leaves
polka and white wine double alcohol all
right let's get started
make it fancy
[Music]
first step most difficult part make dino
nuggets so in the baking see
all the dino nuggets space it out bake
this at 350 for 10 minutes right so this
has been baked and cool to touch i'm
going to remove the breading it's not
coming off quite easy
it's a label of love my favorite memory
of aria it's definitely when he showed
up like a human grape it was a halloween
episode i think it was maybe my favorite
area memory and a favorite halloween
costume too las petra it's kind of like
a i'm
revealing what's inside not the
pleasant view
i separated all nuggets and
breading two
breading parts in oven at 4 25
about 15 minutes and i'm going to use
this naked nugget later breading is
golden brown and crunchy add in a
blender 2 cups of flour 1 tablespoon of
sugar one teaspoon of salt and you want
to blend
until
the breading is very fine add in flour
and blending mixture in a bowl add 10
tablespoons of small cubed butter use
this torture device and using the pastry
cutter costs to cube the butter until
like pea size make sure there is no big
chunk so it looks good add two
tablespoons of vodka add ice cold water
as needed i'm gonna start with two
tablespoons if the dough doesn't come
together i'm gonna add more you kind of
want to do this process pretty quickly
because you don't want to melt those
cold butter so the dough came together
transfer to plastic wrap flat turn this
so it will be easier to roll out later
chill this dough in the refrigerator
about one hour okay so i have some naked
nuggets and i'm going to cut them up
like small dice for one cup adding two
cups of water in a pot and adding half
onion one celery starch 2 small carrots
2 garlic cloves 1 bay leaf thyme and
pasta adding cut up
chicken bring this to a boil and simmer
for 30 minutes it has been simmering for
30 minutes and i'm going to strain dino
broth looks good i'm going to use this
and naked nugget for next step melt 2
tbsp of butter very much with the pan
too today all right butter melted add
half diced onion one stalk of celery one
diced carrot cook those until soft add
salt salt also helps cooking faster and
while it's cooking chop up more naked
dino naked dino making nugget i don't
think you have to censor those it's a
little bit more than a cup but you know
you have more meat veggies look softened
add two tablespoons of flour and cook
for
two minutes just to remove like flour
taste flour looks cooked so i'm going to
add
my second alcohol quarter cup of white
wine degrades the pan a little bit on
the dino broth one cup of naked nugget
adding frozen pea simmer until thickened
and once it's thickened add a quarter
cup of soft half cheese one teaspoon of
thyme two teaspoons of chopped parsley
season to taste transfer this
into a bowl cool this down to room
temperature cover with plastic and chill
in the refrigerator about one hour i
have the dough
use some extra flour on the surface roll
this dough until
thing why do you think the chicken
nugget was invented
let's see
1956.
[Music]
we know
1950s
oh wow
i don't know why i'm so good at this my
pie dough is rolled and i'm going to
start cutting out with
dinosaur cookie cutter unfortunately we
don't have petra so we have
t-rex and triceratops i feel like those
are only two dinosaurs i can pronounce
and remember their name
if you ever need support you'll find a
way to make everything work out oh wow
he's kind of like a mushroom akonahi of
a dinosaur
[Laughter]
why it's the purple dinosaur name
that's
[Music]
i feel like he's maybe the most famous
dinosaur
in america like in japan most famous
dinosaur is godzilla a godzilla it's not
dinosaur
that's it okay so i cut out dinosaur
shape and i'm going to use rolling pin
without losing the shape i'm going to
roll a little bit bigger
it's like how to evolution
put
the filling
you don't want to overfill it you're
going to pinch
the dough
with finger i'm gonna just shape a
little bit look like t-rex you do the
same with triceratops
i think triceratops maybe taste better
because they have more bumpy stuff so
it's gonna be crispier like in a real
life t-rex tastes better because it's
more like
chicken triceratops look like a rhino
and rhino doesn't look like delicious
right so they are looking like dinosaur
and i'm going to
finish with egg wash
egg wash makes finished product shinier
so whenever you make pie
you want to use egg wash or heavy cream
so it will have nice shine okay so i'm
going to make more once you finish
everything you're going to bake up 400
for 20 minutes or until golden brown
right so my dino honda pies looks great
and i'm going to make it more fun i have
like various kind of
vegetables let's do it's broccoli kind
of want to make it look like jurassic
era this kind of has some
good vibes yes i missed that show
because i am a rubra james of daijou you
cook don't you ever forget
i have a nice carrot top so i'm going to
utilize that i think if i put some
carrot top it would look like a volcano
at that time there was some volcano
right
according to some like cartoons and
restoration
they stole nothing and i have some
radish kind of look like a little
mountain could look like a little island
and i'm going to put some dinosaur
it's like all
freestyle so
bear with me
he fell i'm going to give him a little
bit surgery so he can stand pretty cure
how about that does it looks good
it's cute
and we are done
[Music]
dino honda pies let's see what arya
thinks
[Music]
arya
[Music]
it's riya i'm actually a little uh a
little emotional seeing you it's it's
been a while so much time has passed by
that you've had a baby and you haven't
met you want to be called uncle arya
okay children children usually hate me
this thing has been delivered to me it's
been very covertly it's wrapped up i'm
very very very excited do you want to
open it up
what is this what is this magic you made
them look like dinosaurs look
you can show that an art exhibition so
this is a t-rex
yes let's say triceratops yes yes yes
yes and so t-rex is like this right yes
they have tiny arms they wouldn't be
very good cooks if you are dinosaur what
dinosaur are you i would love to be a
little velociraptor you know just like
how does it sound i think a velociraptor
goes like
you have a favorite dinosaur i
like petra
the pterodactyl oh you're a dino nugget
fan i like herbie thank you so much for
it
[Music]
[Music]
delectable this is a chicken pot pie
the fact that you made it the shape of a
dinosaur too i mean that is that makes
it fancy this is fantastic thank you we
have one thing
yes i forgot don't forget we do that oh
my gosh
three two one maybe you're fancy
[Music]
you